the parental rights in education bill
has officially passed the florida state
senate and even before being signed into
law has already made history as the
single most misrepresented piece of
legislation in perhaps the history of
politics
opponents have dubbed it the don't say
gay bill prompting senate democrats in
florida to walk up and down their office
hallways chanting gay
gay
gay
the bill led mark hamill luke skywalker
to tweet the word gay
precisely 69 times
the bill impelled the ceo of disney to
donate five million dollars to gay
causes to plead with ron desantis not to
sign the bill
not to prohibit
the utterance of that apparently sacred
word
gay
but the bill doesn't ban the word gay
the bill doesn't even mention the word
gay
the bill just stops teachers from
preaching
transgenderism and other strange sexual
theories to extremely young school
children in preschool through third
grade
why are democrats so deeply opposed to a
bill that would have been entirely
uncontroversial considered common sense
just five or ten years ago i don't know
which is why i've invited a democrat on
to explain it to me now i need help
making sense of the uproar over this law
which is why i have invited on my friend
ethan behrman ethan berman you know him
you've seen him on tv he is a liberal
california democrat lawyer
ethan thank you for coming on
well michael it is good to join you and
of course i disagree with your uh
this entire premise of uh where this
starts but but it's good to see you this
morning well it's wonderful to see you i
you you are
as far as i can tell
very intelligent
generally normal certainly by california
standards normal common sense-headed
person and yet
you oppose
this law in florida explain to me the
problem with the law
well let's let's start with the
presentation of the law in the first
place there is no sex ed curriculum for
k-3 in the state of florida now nothing
in this bill addresses the curriculum in
the state of florida this is a classic
red meat piece of legislation for a
rabid base that hates the idea of
anybody who is different from them
and so it was really a bill that
addressed nothing that was relevant in
the florida schools in the first place
okay then i'll pause you there for one
second ethan if the bill doesn't
actually take on anything that is going
on in the schools
then what's the big deal why the uproar
about it it's going to be completely
ineffective so who cares
yeah the big the big deal is this is we
already have a minority group of lgbtq
families and students so for example one
of the things that one of the authors
said i can't remember
which republican in florida said this
but basically you can't have an issue
now under this law a teacher in third
grade
giving a word problem in math class
can't say
jimmy and his two moms have that's
against the law under this law to say
jimmy and his two moms the reality is
there are same-sex parents in this
country the reality is there are gay
people in this country to deny a reality
is to diminish their existence which we
know based on data that that actually
has harmful mental health effects on
lgbtq individuals and families so
i want to make a distinction here or at
least delve into this distinction you're
saying that this bill is unfair toward
lgbt people are you referring to the
lgbt
three-year-olds to seven-year-olds that
this bill would affect or are you
referring to the three-year-olds and
seven-year-olds who
whose sexuality we are not talking about
and are not interested in and i you know
i think it's a little creepy even to
talk about five-year-old sexuality but
maybe they've got their father is gay
and so they you know it's johnny has two
daddies or their mother is a lesbian or
something like that and so it's it's
disrespectful to them not to have the
math teacher talk about the lesbian
mothers when doing arithmetic
yeah well first things first it this
affects k through three so i don't think
kindergarten is three-year-olds now i
have kids no it's preschool it's pre-k
through through
i apologize it's pre-k through okay and
then and third grade goes all the way up
to you could be nine years old in in
third grade as well potentially
depending on how well you're doing
second grade
but um
so but but here's the deal
it it's this denying reality this is a
common problem that seems to be
happening in republican circles right
now book banning right we actually have
book banning happening in this country
you can't reject reality you can't
reject
ideas that just because you disagree
that look you and i disagree all the
time does that mean michael that i
reject that your idea should not even
exist
in the public sphere
for fear that it's going to infect
others look i am 100
always have been against white
nationalism for example does that mean i
think that it should never exist well i
would like it to never exist do i think
that everything should be banned and
those people should not be allowed to
speak on that basis by government decree
that's what we're talking about so it's
not a it's not a choice that's being
made it's by government decree that
we're saying something can't be said in
a classroom that idea is should be
antithetical to most people on the right
but you get you mix religion into it and
suddenly people forget their core values
that they supposedly espouse and then
say now we can't say those words at all
in a public space now ethan are you
that's a problem on this topic of
banning books are you of the opinion
that no books should be banned from the
curriculum whatsoever
there's a difference between curriculum
and what's available in a library right
so but we're talking i'm sorry we're
talking about the classroom though right
you know the math teacher talks about
how jane has two mommies we're talking
about the books that are being taught
not necessarily in a health class and
not just what's in a library but the the
sort of ideas and books that are being
brought into the classroom are you of
the opinion that no books should be
banned whatsoever
no
there there are books that should be
banned and and i would go back to the
white nationalist example i don't want
any white nationalist book taught in my
k-3 school because but that should still
be potentially available in a library
somewhere sure if somebody wants to read
and argue that point right i don't agree
with it i don't like it it won't be in
my library but does that mean that the
government should put out a decree that
says it cannot be available no
i don't agree with that so that's where
we are though in this circumstance is
the government is decreeing
that a teacher cannot do a word problem
in third grade that says
jimmy and his two moms
you're breaking the law and now we're
restricting teachers by the way florida
is also proposing putting cameras and
microphones on teachers too this this is
where the slippery slope on the right
seems to be wildly out of control
now
but what what if i were what if math
teacher michael who is catholic
and conservative what if i were teaching
students and i said okay so uh we're
gonna do an arithmetic problem here um
marriage as we all know is a sacred
union between one man and one woman so
you've got one man on one side and one
woman on the other what happens when you
add them together one plus one equals
two would with that statement should
that be banned from the classroom
no
it should not
so if if you think if you think that and
you believe that uh and you can disagree
with it
the the key here is
are you going to be preaching
catholicism in a public classroom now i
just did wow i just didn't but now you
have to allow then at the same time so
there's a difference if if it's
espousing a specific religious belief
and you don't allow a contradictory
opinion i think we have problems
okay then on that on that that's a very
good point
on that point when the left some leftist
teacher espouses a very specific
religious belief namely that it's
totally morally acceptable for
men and men to be the same as men and
women or that men can become women and
women can become men that's a religious
belief it's called
gnostic dualism among others of course
it's religious it's about the nature
of course i mean by ethan by definition
it's religious you're talking about the
nature of morality you're talking about
the nature of humanity you're talking
about the relationship between our soul
and our body how much more religious can
you get
yeah it's not because it's not part of a
catechism for example from a church
that's where you start church of leftism
i think ethan no that's not an official
church is that a is that is this the
state church in this country
the irs runs it really isn't though so
that's a nonsensical argument that the
wright likes to use but the the issue
here still comes down to a key fact
there are gay people there are same
characters no one's denying i want to
deny that reality in a classroom to kids
because you somehow have a belief that
is so weak that you can't hear those
words and you don't have a strong enough
home where you're teaching them what you
believe your own children that they can
never hear something that contradicts
what you believe that's weakness by the
way the supreme court just under 100
years ago affirmed you're right michael
to send your kids to a private catholic
school is actually over catholicism in
1925 that the supreme court ruled that
you have the right to send your kid to a
private school right now but ethan but
ethan my taxpayer dollars are going
toward the public schools and i think
this is a pretty modest ask to suggest
that people who are little kids who are
three to seven or eight or even for your
slow second grade or nine years old uh
in these classrooms that they not be
exposed to radical theories about sex
and gender which have been held in moral
opprobrium by virtually every
civilization for all of human history
that they not be exposed to that before
they're even hitting the age of reason
this seems like a relatively minor ask
to me it seems like a pretty radical
political agenda on the other side
that's seeking to imbue the math
curriculum with transgenderism and novel
notions of marriage we've got we're
already past time but i want to give you
the last word
yeah i i just disagree with that and
it's already not in the curriculum it's
prohibiting something that isn't even
happening and it's demeaning so the math
teacher is not talking a section of our
population the math teacher is not going
to say talk about johnny's two moms and
his dad who became a mother it might now
because you made an issue of it
well then i get i guess it's on us but
i'm glad there's a law at least to to
stop that kind of radicalism that
perhaps i guess we impelled it in the
first place but i'm glad we won't see
any more ethan where can people find you
just ethanberryman.com and you can find
me on twitter at ethan berman ethan
thank you very much you have given me a
broader perspective of this law but i
still think you are entirely wrong thank
you for coming on ethan thanks michael
head on over to expressvpn.com
knowles how did you choose your internet
service provider
i know how you chose it
for the vast majority of people you
didn't have a choice because the isps
operate like monopolies in the regions
they serve and they use that monopoly
power to take advantage of customers and
they log your internet activity and they
sell those data to other big tech
companies and advertisers
all those data
even the stuff that you're searching for
on your little incognito window you know
things that maybe you shouldn't be
looking at according to the powers that
be you know saucy websites like for
instance the daily wire
you don't want that stuff getting logged
when you go online use a vpn
it's as simple as that actually
yesterday when i was looking up some
things that were a little bit critical
of some of government's policies it
occurred to me as i was doing it oh my
gosh i forgot to turn my vpn on at the
top of this setting i turned it off
briefly just to kind of restart it i
renewed my subscription
don't when you go online use that vpn
it's so easy with expressvpn you just
click one button on your computer on
your mobile device do not hand over your
data to tech go to expressvpn.comvpn.com
knowles to get three extra months for
free expressvpn.com knowles head on over
there right now to learn more i'm so
glad you liked that clip
ring the bell please ring that bell
subscribe and then head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
maybe leave a five star review we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you